LAST TIME THE TEAMS MET WITH A
SECOND IN REG PLAY.
BACK THE OTHER WAY WENT JASON
DICKINSON TO OPEN THE SCORING
AND
POSITION ON THE OTHER PLAY.
AND LOOK AT WHERE KAHKONEN ENDS.
A SLASHING CALL.
AN KILL ADVANTAGE, SAN
JOSE TIES THE GAME AND THE
SHARKS WILL STAY TWO DEFENCEMANE
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE TRIANGLE
AND HER ALONE, A SHOT
AND A GLOVE SAVEHECKED, NOW PODN
WITH A SHOT STOPPED BY KAHKONEN.
COUTURE GOT A SHOT AWAY.
HEADING WIDE BY DEMODKOLZIN, ANS
BLOCKED BY VLASIC.
PUCK UP PUCK
BACK TOOUTURE
JUST AS THE PEN GO AHEAD GOAL HE
JUST SHY OF THEAND GARLAND'S GOK
THAT HURT G.: THATCHER DEMKO,
GOGO ON THE BACKHAND
BUT STOPPED BY THATCHER DEMKO. A
WRIST SHOT OFF THE SHOULDER OF
HIS WRIST SHOT HIT THE POST!
BEAT DEMKO STICK SIDE BUT STAYE.
BOUNCED OFF HIS STICK THROUGH TO
DEMKO AS RUDOLFS BALCE GOAL,
NOAH GREGOR STOPPED BY DEM PADSF
KAHKONEN.
REFEREE CAME FLYING INT WIDE, WK
CLEARING ATTEMPT KEPK OUT,
COUTURE WITH A BACKHANDER
STOPPED BY DEMKO AND HEAST DEMKE
GAME AT TWO.ND MATT
NIETO IN FRONT OF
PETTERSSON.
PETTERSSON SHARP ANGLE SHOT HIT
AFTER THE SAVE BY KAHKONEN, AND
IT'S 3-2 SKATE AND WOUND UP
ON THE OR THE CROSSBAR.
AND CLEARED AWAY BY THE HE'S BAE
>> John G.: THAT'S GOING TO
COUNT.
>> John S.: LUKE SCHENN BEAT
THE BUZZER.RIGHT THERE.
ABLE TO GET IT